[Music]
this week on the dish
an immigrant success story born in
lebanon chef eddie massey says
he'd like to be the middle eastern
martha stewart at just 26 he appears to
be on his way
from food to layout massey does it all
it started with a creative spin on
mediterranean apps from hummus to baba
ganoush to stuffed grape leaves
now it's his latest venture launched in
the midst of the pandemic
in his very own green point brooklyn new
york neighborhood
when i first moved in it just felt like
a little poland in a way
eddie massey has watched firsthand as
his once predominantly polish
brooklyn neighborhood has diversified a
prime example
his self-named store standing here in
this neighborhood
and seeing your sign your place what
does this mean to you
it means a lot to me i mean it's crazy
to think that i came from a small
fishing village in the north side of
lebanon to this now
in the middle of one of the biggest
cities in the world inside eddie's
grocer
a taste of his homeland including an
array of middle eastern spreads
side dishes and traditional lebanese
entrees
all with massey's own spin you've got
the rizage right there
which is a lebanese dirty rice right
here
is what we call it it's a chickpea and
eggplant stew
it was some of his favorites we tasted
here we've got zatar chicken which is my
little invention
as massey shared his journey to the
united states from lebanon
at age 10. my parents wanted us to come
my sister and i did not want to come
that's for sure
we loved our life and i think at that
age it's a very hard
move especially because we didn't speak
the language massey admits
it was work learning english and just
fitting
in like in the school cafeteria which
he'd
only known from the american tv show
lizzie mcguire
what are you eating peanut butter and
banana sandwich
showing up to a cafeteria with a labnae
tartine
and like lebanese bread rolled up and
kids being like
what are you eating hummus wasn't a
thing like it is now right
where somebody would look over my
shoulder be like you're eating poop that
looks like poop and you're like oh god
but at home that same food was a part of
the fabric of his family
food is like the masterpiece of our life
in lebanon i think every
day all you do is join your family
around a big meal
and you're always talking about the next
meal where are we eating what are we
cooking
so with both of his parents working
massey took over in the family kitchen
by high school he started to see a
future in food
launching a cooking club and creating
his own cooking show
airing on local cable where were your
parents in
being okay with all of this because
sometimes parents have other thoughts of
what our future is
you they did my dad was very supportive
because my dad loves to eat it's like
his favorite thing so
he he was very supportive and i think
that his dad made him do
something else that he wanted to do so
he was like you do what you want my mom
did not want me to cook what did she
want you to do
she just just not gross anything but
cook
he enrolled in the culinary institute of
america anyway
but it was his suspension from it for
plagiarism
that gave massey direction that's when
he got a job at famed restaurateur danny
meyer's
north end grill i say this all the time
but you can skip culinary school and go
work for danny meyer
the way his system is done and how
everything is so well thought out
in front of the house back in the house
did you have a desire
to sort of finish what you had started
though everybody that i was working with
all my managers were
culinary street america graduates so
they helped me get back to school
massey finished his degree while working
for meyer
then got out of the restaurant business
and into people's homes in 2016 he began
catering middle eastern spreads and
meals that were as appetizing to the
eyes as the stomach
he quickly gained notoriety for his
platters known as
brown paper boards thanks to their
signature look
when i started i was praying for like
one to two events a week
right like literally i was like i hope i
can get one dinner
and the really height of it all i
remember one week i did 22 events
then last march kovit brought his
catering business to a halt
massey tried doing delivery out of his
own kitchen
but hit a snag the new york post heard
about me
they wrote me up which was amazing my
sales tripled that week
and then right after that the health
department called and was like this is a
no-no
and they shut me down over the phone and
i was like well what am i going to do
now
this corner store was the answer his
go-to sandwich shop maria's deli
owner maria puke had moved to the
neighborhood from poland
when she was 10. she worked as a
kid in the grocery store and she used to
hand deliver groceries and stock it
and then she took it over when she
turned
22. wow she has been working and running
that deli for 43 years until massey took
over
last july he leased the space from maria
kept touches of her within
and in the midst of the pandemic
transformed it into eddie's grocer
in just six weeks where do you get
the energy the brain power the vision
where does all that come from
cold brew you know my parents sacrificed
a lot for us when we moved here they
gave up a lot we
lived a really great lifestyle in
lebanon
and they gave it all up for our future
and i think that
every day work hard to prove to them
that they did it for a reason
like his chosen career believing if his
family hadn't moved to the u.s
he wouldn't be a chef and that as a gay
man in a small town in lebanon
he probably never would have come out
you're a lebanese-american
gay chef it's a lot of labels but
certainly diverse
and unique i am the voice of those
little boys in that town and
those little boys in all the towns of
lebanon to be able to
jump that leap and be proud of who i am
it's something that
they might never experience as for
massey's next leap
oh god this is your life eddie yeah i
know
i'm trying to figure that question out
do i know where i'm going
no am i happy with where we're going yes
also happy his parents including his mom
you may remember didn't want him to be a
chef
he says they're even thinking about
moving from massachusetts to new york
city so they can help him
with the store and i couldn't leave my
cohorts
hanging this is like a mini version of
these brown paper boards with some of
the spreads
absolutely delicious and really works of
art
the color is just amazing
do not be surprised if you see eddie
massey one day on your tv screen
with all of this that's great do we know
what all these i actually don't know
what he sent to us and because we can't
reach i mean obviously there's some
olives there and
um i think some tabbouleh and that mix
as well so basically we can't
we're gonna dive in we are gonna dive in
here oh there you go okay